will the farter came in well there he is
look at him man hey would you bulk up
you look pretty uh you're pretty ripped
with muscular we should gas masks Gary
Gary's gonna be holding the microphone
for well we will staring at Gary not bad
okay this is how I think you should
dress every day first of all will said
hey I heard your book went to number one
on this Apple Liz so will got in touch
with us instead of Howard wants a twenty
one fart salute I'll give it I'll give
it to him
that's how he said it I'll give it to
him and I thought that was awfully
generous of you thank you no prom I've
never heard anyone fart as good as you
in terms of not only length but the
actual sound the vibration and the
length of time and the amount of farts
you can get out in any session it almost
seems limitless it's an amazing power do
you attribute that to the fact that you
were born without an anus yeah I do yes
when you were born you had no anus
whatsoever
I had no opening yes all this [ __ ] was
in there but it just couldn't go out
yeah I had a close to me bag for a year
or more
right and then you had a doctor who said
hey I can just cut a hole back there you
give this guy an [ __ ] yes and in a
way when they built you a new [ __ ]
pretty much yeah you got a superpower
out of it apparently but but I think if
I said that's your origin story it is
and I I'm I'm feeling as if my
superpowers might be waning but I can
still do oh no I can still do it what's
happening I probably get a colonoscopy
why as of like I think it was about a
year or two ago
go ahead I started having issues where
I'd bleed for no reason out of your
[ __ ] oh yeah I think it's either a
fissure a hemorrhoid or something you're
not losing your powers are yeah I don't
I don't think I'm losing it but I'm
afraid if I go to the colonoscopy and
they do some work oh no no no you got to
talk to the doctor um you haven't you
have a special power you have a career
yeah but it's weird like you are
definitely a superhero because they call
an Oscar pees could be your kryptonite
it could you could take away your powers
there's gold over there and that evening
I I definitely think so let's do it well
this is an honor of the book of Howard
Stern comes again for Christmas okay
that's warmup okay tell us when it
starts right was that okay he's ready oh
my god you've not lost your powers there
is no enhancement on this
I wish Madam Secretary was how many we
up to will lost count has he ever been
better
do you count that it's 3 or 1 Gary I
think we're 21 I don't think so I think
sucking first oh it's gonna come
lawnmower oh it's still coming
go ahead take your time you're at the
top of your game y'all right now that's
good oh my god what do you mean you
pulled your neck every now and then I
[ __ ] for some reason my right side so
partings like like they calm Brady it's
not something that's easy
I usually sweat my ass off every time I
do this you're a master have you put in
10,000 hours this yeah probably over the
years yeah will the farter forever not
if he gets that colonoscopy no but he's
a mess you got to stay in really good
shape for this don't you
it's a muscle control yeah it's also
core to E or yeah core they talk about
that a lot
well you've done it again you you honor
me with the 21 part salute our audience
I know loved it
what can I say you are the world
premiere party